Britain's Royals will soon welcome an
American to the family Prince Harry and
actress Megan Merkel appear at a short
time ago after their engagement was
announced and they're planning a spring
wedding Charlie d'Agata is at Kensington
Palace in London with what the prince
and his fiancee have in common charlie
good morning well good morning and cause
for celebration here at Kensington
Palace and we have reaction from the
queen whose people tweeted that she and
Prince Philip are delighted for the
couple and wish them every happiness
while Prince Charles says he is thrilled
and very happy indeed they look like any
newly engaged couple Mike loved up and
barely containing their excitement and
the first glance at the diamond
engagement ring made by the court
jewelers to the Queen but while it may
be a fairytale romance it has a
thoroughly modern twist
Roy Anika royal correspondent it's a
wonderful fairy tale it's it's someone
from a different country different
background marrying into our royal
family but above all they look so happy
together When Harry Met Megan Markel was
already famous in her own right a star
of the hit drama series suits the 36
year old from Los Angeles shot to fame
in her role of Rachel Zane the two met
through mutual friends in London and for
a time managed to keep their
relationship secret it was here in
London Harry
popped the question earlier this month
they share an interest in charity in
promoting worthy causes
shortly before meeting Markel in 2016
Harry sat down with Norah O'Donnell at
the Invictus games in Florida do you
want to have kids someday
for that question to that of course time
you know time time time will tell it was
at this year's Invictus games that the
couple made their first public
appearance and while here in Britain the
support for the relationship has been
overwhelming Harry's choice of an
independently wealthy divorced famous
not to mention American star may be a
bit of a break from tradition
then again 'harry was never the type to
let something like that get in the way
of a perfect fit now getting married
doesn't change Prince Harry's position
he was fifth in line to the throne he
slides back to sixth in line to the
throne after Kate has her baby in April
yeah it's great news all the way around
from London thank you so much charlie
it's amazing how excited you can get
about people that you don't really even
know you've met him I've met him I can't
say I know him by any stretch of the
imagination don't know her but the
family trees changing she's biracial
she's divorced a lot of people excited
about that but I like what that reporter
said everybody says they look so happy
together yeah I found him so authentic
and movies desire to help wounded
warriors was was quite inspiring so
looking forward to that it's more to
that